David, do you think vaccination phases
are ethical once you get to vaccinating
health care workers? Is it really ethical to
limit who can get the vaccine? Beyond that,
I mean, listen, this is basic utilitarian
utilitarianism. It's triage. You
try to reduce the amount of death and
people who get seriously ill from covid,
if that's the goal, if we all agree that those
statistically more likely to get a cold flu like
are in one group and those statistically more
likely to die from covid are in another group,
it's completely utilitarian to say they get
the vaccine first. So you would start with
the oldest folks and those with the most serious
medical conditions. There's nothing particularly
unique about that. It's simply utilitarianism.
Now, where it can get tricky is the practice of
figuring out where some of these lines are.
So, for example, throughout the pandemic,
grocery store workers have been essential,
essential workers. So we've heard the term,
but they've not been prioritized. We know that so
many grocery store workers have gotten sick with
the virus and we're saying they're essential, but
they're not being prioritized. Maybe it's being
done incorrectly. But the idea of figuring out at
least when there's limited supply who can get the
vaccine first is perfectly utilitarian. Now, you
can look at other criteria. You could say, well,
we want this to be egalitarian and so we're
going to do it by lottery. As an example,
you could make the case that that's preferable
in some way. It's not likely to reduce death.
The studies that I've looked at do say that
starting with the oldest and the sickest
is the way to reduce that death. And in fact,
we're seeing it. If you look at the numbers now,
cases have sort of plateaued. They've
plateaued right around 50000 today.
And hospitalizations keep declining and
deaths keep declining. Now, the deaths
are on a delay from cases. So we'll have to
continue to watch that. But that makes sense
because you you tend to have people behave in a
way that's reflective of the risk they perceive.
There are definitely younger people. As we
now learn about more and more older folks
being vaccinated, there are more younger
people doing whatever the hell they want,
spreading covid. It's leading to cases, but the
deaths and hospitalizations are going down because
the most vulnerable have already been vaccinated.
So I do believe that as vaccine supply increases,
the restrictions probably become I don't know
if the word is less ethical, but less necessary.
And certainly any thought vaccine should be used
no matter what. There are some anecdotal stories
and we've covered some of them of people
who have been penalized and in some cases,
I believe, even fired for using open doses,
which would go bad if you leave them overnight
on people who did not yet meet criteria. I think
that's terrible. And to the extent that it's
happening anecdotally, it shouldn't. It's very
bad people. We should be using every single dose.
A dose in a trash can is never better, no matter
what, than a dose in someone's arm. But yes, from
a utilitarian standpoint, and this is a common way
to analyze some of these medical ethics issues,
there's nothing unethical about the vaccine
triage. And it does appear as though it's being
done more or less in the right way. But there
are arguments to be made about, well, teachers
maybe should have been earlier if they're going
to have to be in schools with kids, if grocery
workers really are essential, we know a lot of
them are getting sick. They should be on. I think
you can tweak with with some of the specifics,
but there's nothing unethical in principal.